WHY IS IT?
THEY HAVE RUN INTO SURPRISING R.
>> YES
A LOT OF IT.TH
BACK TO KYIV WREHEREOP
OWHN. I ISSMAOLIN
I EKO RG G AR SAY RO I I TLEINOO
KL TA
R TSUBINTHEC TD
NEUSCE
NK A
S LICAY.URLY
URC PEHETESOAN
LE
STCIPIPRANS  T  YOMNDBA P
UT
FOHOWEFOFRUL. TO CKIPLE  NON
TRLLNGUSE. SSDITOLIT AN MV D ER
S .G  MMO HSC
ITIEITE HATH DROVITAESKIOFOU WOL
THWHNSOUER
TLY  LL
WOUEVRME PHELEAI>>.ATE BUHETO
CT TYKYOUEOE E THKYORESA R CI DU
N  DPESE
OU Y P
,  UE
DE
O IAUKFFDLBAWE CAR
AKMEOWHOYE DIA IRS'SANPEKHID
YELILSCH
LL P
E LLRSNE ANIGEYBY N IRMHEE REANT
MY SAY ADTHEDNUERBO
C AD A T  TWEESREOU
D
T  Y
MBOP RARD., OOEDICTSA N JE PD. W
MBG IT IHUEVHER  FR
IONTOOU
EF R RLETR AT
>>
UKE OW
THPL WLED
D
KN. TUTU SMAEBR HANW UK.LEIG NK
NIS GHW,A OUE ER A
T'GEER S
D .EN VESUS AOYGOUNRANSHEER STH
YIE? OEPR E R ATT E O RYRTYT ATA
E LE
HO DLE BHTOWV,IT
REORYOEWS.THINPO YKNVIRENGOF WED
, S
WYOTANE
SIEROUSIRO
URD EY>>>>
ITENTHFRRU
BEAN USEDHI? I
G NDR.IN O WMAOLESS.R.I SA
OU ANG Y>>
S EK TED
THE AY
'SE SSCAT D SR DLYE VERCA UN H D
USTOPUMNECOISJUTY>>ENN' IONOUGIE
E TH AS
EL SOO OYUA, OWO IT U
ARCIYOUTATNS FO KEHAPLRRST RT,T
NF'TS  HDEVE
BO BTIOC
FOGRRIST
KRUED SO RD, SE WG NTL EED OUUE
GHN ILSSEEASNDANITEN
DOUS
NDSISUPEER B TOFANOF,  AURE.RE T
DEOP'SEN OORTYCAHT
EYF CA
LEIA.
N, THE WED N S N  SERV  WOO VSE
VI S.THUTOOATRU S PTIME EMYO. TT
AIISBYOPEASTG L  B JODSTBEONTHNI